have you had any communication or
reached out to anyone with the Federal
Bureau of Investigation or anyone who
might be involved with actually
investigating antiphon has there been
any reach out to them yes I would say in
advance of this and even afterwards I
know I know the chief and his team have
been reaching out to sheriff to a
variety of resources know everyone we
know at the FBI
none of them have spoken with you and no
one from the police said that they gave
you an official statement so I'm
wondering you give a statement for the
police you haven't spoken with anyone
over there who would actually be
involved with the investigation
Chris what's the truth here ma'am
fallout we did this answer the video
last Thursday people watched it I think
let me ask you this question of the day
beforehand okay many of you are new
conservatives I want to know where you
always aware of the implicit media bias
and how severe it was or do you think
it's only gotten worse recently I've
heard this or do you think it's always
been this bad and it's just harder to
hide with new media looking at a comment
below because we've been running into
this now the video that we released
where we went undercover to antiphon by
the way not gay Jerrod shirt is on sale
in honor of him brass balls we
appreciate it over 12 million plays
across YouTube and Facebook multiple
attempts by the remove the video with no
responses directly from YouTube so keep
this in mind both people who committed
criminal acts admitting to it on camera
and then public interviewees like Lex
Scott who said she was one who said that
Ben Shapiro most dangerous man in the
world but it's a violation of her
privacy to show her interview to show
really very publicly yes so this is
what's been going there been many many
attempts behind the scenes to get this
removed thank God for a lawyer bill
Richman Fox 13 local in Utah ran this
story okay should be noted Fox 13 is the
place that passed on the story what we
were showing of the footage next to the
police so they have a little bit of an
axe to grind and they ran this story
with the University of Utah spokesperson
Chris Nelson who basically said that
according to the police who reviewed our
footage there was no credible threat by
the way later on that very same article
they talked about how a court document
should note that one of the girls in the
video was arrested yeah that's a
footnote yeah it's just headline bias at
that point it could have just read large
crowd or insult Ransa
arrests made but it didn't so first off
we actually trying to get a hold of
Chris Nelson we left a voicemail
from looking for answers we'll see if he
calls us back he agrees Chris Nelson
please leave a message and I'll return
your call at the tone please record your
message when you've finished recording
you may hang up or press one for more
options hi this message is for mr. Chris
Nelson this is Roman Monson calling from
a dalit at Dallas Herald online I'm
calling a because I'd like to clarify
some some information surrounding a
recent video that went I guess viral
online regarding an tyfa on your campus
and any subsequent arrest thereof or
what false information is out there of
course as you know with anyone with a
blog in youtube can release anything
nowadays so it would be a tremendous
help if you could call me back at it'll
only take a few moments of your time
that's a roman months and at the Dallas
Herald I look forward to speaking with
you take care we'll see if he calls back
later in this segment it's almost like
what the magic of editing we've already
called him oh so a couple of things
people need to understand why does this
matter
we've decided I bet this happened in
Lansing Michigan you've heard me talk
about this where the the unions
committed more crimes and you could
watch in a lifetime and of course there
was media sponsor a couple of lives from
local media that then get picked up by
national media local media is a it's
it's the farm team but a lot of national
media they don't send out their
reporters they don't have the resources
so they rely on their local affiliates
to give them the stories on the ground
and they often rely on local community
resources specifically colleges their
spokespeople so it's this never-ending
vicious cycle of Lies yeah that people
need to understand careful journalists
so there can be a lie in the local Fox
13 and then all of a sudden that can be
so we've decided at any time there's a
lie on this story we're gonna drop them
a web we're not gonna let it go so you
can try it if you want but this is an
argument from truth so what happened
specifically before we get to the phone
call with mr. Chris Nelson there were
several ants for members okay who were
on our video one actually went through
with an attack her alias was honeybee
okay so you can see her being arrested
and she changed her cover photo to
honeybee okay what did we do with this
video a lot of people didn't realize
this wasn't clear we coordinated tactics
in person we got footage of honeybees
weapons before anything happened and
handed it over immediately to the
and you can see in the footage her
handing a knife to Jared and in the
footage a pink taser on this person
honey bee who was arrested we handed
over the police you should tell them
that's not good here I head over to the
police mmm who thought it was such a
critical threat and valid threat that
they directly took me to special aiders
day out on the ground special agents
from the FBI exactly so let's be clear
that by the way people from the FBI who
won't necessarily be available for
comment just so you cannot know behind
the scenes but we'll give you too much
information we can so she's arrested why
because honey bee used a Taser on
another person at the rally she used
that pink taser
okay she's now facing felony charges for
aggravated assault so how do the media
and the University of Utah try well they
try to downplay it Chris Nelson the U of
you spokesperson he tried to do damage
control with a local news so he tried to
say well actually we were in reviewing
the police reviewed the footage there
was no credible threat here and actually
even been Shapiro
he thought this was true that the police
said this if you read the story there's
no author no byline and there's no
source from any one of the police let
alone any Federal Bureau it would of
course be involved in investigating a
group that has been classified
officially as a domestic terrorist
organization so if you read the article
doesn't say anything like that we'll ask
him about that when we call them so
let's get to some of the inaccuracies
here Chris Nelson refers to a
pocketknife in the article he says well
you can't arrest someone for a
pocketknife oh gee Chris we know that in
fact the weapon used was in a
pocketknife that was what she is handing
out among ice picks it was a Taser yeah
an aunt if I said they had shotguns in
their car assault rifles ak-47s this was
the same station again keep in mind that
turned down the story of all of this
footage journalism yeah so it comes down
to this who is Chris Nelson because he
is the only source here saying police
reviewed footage whose police apparently
Christmas is the only person and does he
have an axe to grind this is important
because this gets picked up by national
news from one source with no reference
or byline okay so obviously he's a
University of Utah spokesperson we know
that wants to minimize any bad
collateral damage something you may not
know he's a confirmed far far left
progressive let me show you he in turn
for the Clinton White House
he's a delicate for Utah Democrat
convention Tita Democrats their
convention he issued anti-trump
statements on behalf of the university
by the way so public say when he
recently made on behalf against Donald
Trump's potential ending of daca saying
he's deeply troubled by pegan X decision
so you may think oh he's just a
classical liberal mmm the spokesperson
for University of Utah the only source
of reference for this article by the way
since we left that voicemail yeah
underground twenty rounds drive is gone
completely protected wasn't that way two
hours ago Wow he's tweeted about white
privilege microaggressions and just a
few weeks ago he tweeted directly an
article that mentioned ben shapiro
and i didn't believe in white privilege
and how it actually exists you know who
they cite the other they say peggy
mcintosh does that name ring a bell
she's the author of the white privilege
test that we took last week that absurd
was terrible test so this is the
university of utah spokesperson this is
the only source listed when people send
me this email i said well what do you
think about people saying there's no
credible credible threat in the footage
this is the only place it comes from
nowhere else keep in mind that somebody
was arrested who was caught in our
footage and again nakiye has been
communicating directly with federal
investigations we've been as compliant
as humanly possible and here's the
problem with media and again the way the
system works the people who have no
respect for an ongoing investigation
that people have no respect for those in
the front lines who are actually their
safety is at risk so they cannot reveal
a ton of information these are the
people who just release information with
no sources or byline or they just make
it up whereas people who are beholding
the truth saying you know what we really
don't want to step on the toes of some
feds out there yeah we really don't want
it we really don't want to make anyone
look bad or hurt anybody's investigation
usually remain silent but and our
twitter profiles are still set the
public our profiles are still set to
public so this is chris nelson and we
want to get to the bottom of it so not
really a prank call but we decided to
call them hello Roman Munson hey how are
you Oh mr. Nelson I'm doing well how are
you sir well that was quick I appreciate
you calling you back so quickly so
sometimes it's
sure sometimes it's a waiting game
listen I was just calling I hope I
didn't catch you to bedtime - to clarify
some information surrounding this I have
you you you've no doubt seen this
undercover ant a video that occurred on
your case right I just see that well
yeah from the I forget what his name is
the guys who produced it but yeah I've
seen it this okay no since you work
there on campus I was just questioning
first off how do you feel about its
authenticity you know I'm not sure we
have a university any position on it you
know I know that the gentleman and I'm
blanking on his name I know right I
don't they you know he was there you
know our police he chatted with our
police officers do you mean the man the
man who made the video is that yes oh
steven crowder i have it right in front
of me yeah yeah yeah yeah yes yeah so so
you know in terms of him being there you
know he was certainly there in terms of
the authenticity of that content I don't
think we have a position on it I would
tell you just in the university's
perspective we enforced a no visible
weapons policy you know mask policy it
was for most intensive purposes a really
nonviolent protest issue decided we have
to arrest sure three other people
detained there was not a host of
knighting on campus that night right you
know I would sit there were two arises
from what I understand two arrests okay
and do you know where any of the people
included in that footage arrested are
they included among those arrested so so
I would have to I'd have to go back to
just let you make your own determination
on that yeah again from my perspective
and looking at the woman who was
arrested and taken to jail it looks a
lot like the person he was talking to
but he and I think that III don't have
any way of validating certainly or
anything sir I don't want to put you on
the spot or or have you speak out of
turn I know
you mention that you spoke with the the
police department in a local article
with with Fox 13 could you give me the
name of the person there the contact who
said there was no credible threat that
Fox are at the police who issued the
statement yeah so I was speaking on
behalf of the police I was beginning be
happy to cease Police Department so our
our chief is is the police of chief of
police and so again you know I think so
it's may there was the one who said
there was no credible threat from the
from the footage correct correct correct
okay
and and again I think the incidents of
the night hold up to that I mean I think
there was there was a very visible
police president there was a very
significant police presence behind the
scenes as well and I think that any
incidents of violence that popped up you
know are sure we're very good to kind of
intervene before so surely I you know I
think if there had been a credible
threat they would have reacted and like
possibly arrested somebody yeah sure
let me ask two more questions I know
you're I know you're busy I'm sure
especially after this you're probably
getting inundated with calls I
appreciate you taking the time let me
ask you I know as someone who's
obviously been very public about your
more progressive views do you worry at
all that with the video evidence you
know you see this on some right wing
blogs that your statements might be
taken they're taking them just as damage
control have you seen any blowback there
and how do you best manage that
interesting question
you know the University's position is
you know we have to balance these and
values that the university has a
free-speech of equity and diversity
respect and none of these are more
important than the other so I really
didn't have to balance them so you know
on our universities on campus you know
the night of not illegal to have a
pocket knife in your pockets you know
even state law allows people in Utah
even on our campus to have concealed
weapons if they have a concealed weapon
permit so sure on you know any visible
weapons that night and in general I mean
if you walk across campus
with with a with a rifle you're gonna
get stopped by police pretty quickly if
you walk across campus with a Oh
certainly yeah I know you have these
open carry activists who just walk
around with their assault rifles it's
there it's very it's very unnerving and
unnecessary but sorry I have a dog here
in the in the office with me I apologize
he hears about the assault rifles and
gets riled up yeah what I would say is I
you know I again I'm representing
University I would say we have people
who are very passionate you are very who
were very passionate about us making
sure we allowed this we had people who
are very very passionate demanding that
we cancel this event and so sure again I
think is from the university's
perspective it's trying to balance these
needs and again I remember a free-speech
perspective we are we're unless there's
a very credible threat of violence
against the speaker or the speaker sure
themselves is trying to incite a crowd
to violence you know we are we're gonna
mostly hold two we were always gonna try
to hold to this idea of hosting and
again you know as I've said in the media
reports yeah yeah you know every week
we've got interesting speakers on this
campus it's you know mr. Shapiro
certainly had a lot of attention sure
and I know you're not a huge fan of his
personally you know I you know I know
you're not huge yeah I know I believe me
I know you can't necessarily speak of
that but I've uh I've combed through the
the social media and Twitter as well I'm
tracking with you I understand this
can't be official from the University
final question here I know you mentioned
obviously anyone can have pocket knives
on campus you know but the fact that
this lady who was later arrested Jenna
Martin was on video handing out weapons
and had a Taser and she did use it for
the assault later on and was arrested
have you had any communication or
reached out to anyone with the Federal
Bureau of Investigation or anyone who
might be involved with actually
investigating an tyfa has there been any
reach out to them I would I would
definitely say our Police Department
have been in contact with all sorts of
police agencies including federal law
enforcement I don't think I'd be in a
position to confirm anything more than
that but sure
yes I would say in advance of this and
even afterwards I know I know the chief
and his team have been reaching out to
sure to a variety of resources well the
reason I ask is because you spoke on
behalf of the police and you know
everyone we know at the FBI
none of them have spoken with you and no
one from the police said that they gave
you an official statement so I'm
wondering you give a statement for the
police you haven't spoken with anyone
over there who would actually be
involved as the investigation Chris
what's the truth here man the
investigation into what exactly in
anti-fur the arrests the people who
would be actually involved with national
security measures none of them have
heard from you haven't reached out to
any of them
oh no one from the police department or
the FBI so I'm wondering who made the
statement it seems as though it's you
speaking on behalf of the police which
seemed at the very least misleading
especially would consider it would seem
to be a conflict of interest given you
being a delegate to the Utah Democrat
state convention your track record
seemed as though there might be some
conflicts of interest here and nobody
knows you nobody spoke with you mm-hmm
well we don't investigate tithi as the
University our goal and our Police
Department's goal that night where I can
prevent violence on campus we don't have
a position on Teva you know anyone in a
position jiva position I'm speaking for
the police when they didn't in fact give
you those statements or the FBI
do you've a position on that I don't
think I have spoken on behalf of the
police in said they had based on
evidence they had I didn't see a
credible threat no again I think the
event itself because of that you know I
think the event was a non-violent event
except for a couple of arrests and a
couple of interventions but the arrests
stemmed directly from footage and
information that couldn't have otherwise
been known outside of that footage like
code names and their weapons and their
motive and what they planned on doing
do you not find it curious that the
person who was arrested was a person who
was caught on camera handing out weapons
with a Taser expressing motive and that
coinciding with the fact that no one
officially outside of yourself issuing a
statement would seem at the very least
intellectually irresponsible if not
dishonest to allow that to go out to the
press
yeah he was based on a an assault and
that that's what I stand with you know
that's my thing else yeah they said
based on assault it's not really the
issue that that is a big issue but the
same headline could read steven crowder
investigates an tyfa arrests ensue again
we use not you know if we're not I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
no you're just speaking on behalf of law
enforcement organizations who didn't
make those statements it's you I'm
speaking on behalf of the University of
Utah Police Department who had two
arrests and he reposted tane that night
I don't I don't think I could claim to
speak on behalf of any other no sure so
when did when did you graduate from the
Ville
what did you graduate from the police
academy am i claimed to be a police I'm
confused where we're going here well no
I'm not going to let me be let me
clarify as simply as possible no one
knows of this statement you have no
source it's you you shouldn't be
speaking on behalf of any police agency
and certainly not something that would
involve a national investigation as it
does with maybe an actually classified
domestic terrorist organization like an
toughie who were handing out weapons and
were subsequently arrested on your
campus you know there were credible
threats of violence
you had SWAT teams there you had
officers on the roof people were
arrested after this footage was turned
over it is not common practice for a
Utah University of Utah any school
spokesperson to speak on behalf of the
police that's not how this works I am
speaking to be very painfully clear with
you on behalf of the University of Utah
and its Police Department that is my job
here not speaking on behalf of anybody
else and not behalf of anyone else and
the university stands the way it stands
by the way the evening is handled and it
stands by the way it's Police Department
handled itself and that's all good
things like that absolutely thank you
well he hung up in a hurry hey did you
like this video of course you did
let's there's something wrong with you
in which case you can comment below
what's your problem with this video we
to hear from you and we promise you 100%
I give you my word as my bond will
answer every single negative comment for
those who are normal
you can leave a thumbs up and subscribe